this is the iphone 12 mini and these are
some of the most googled search terms
about it
iphone 12 mini size iphone 12 mini
screen size
iphone 12 mini size comparison iphone 12
mini battery size
i think people want to know about size
instead of a longer normal review this
is a mini review of the iphone 12 mini
since it's basically the same phone as
the iphone 12
just a smaller screen and battery plus i
already reviewed the iphone 12 and all
its new features
so how many is mini it's all about
perspective
the mini is smaller than a lot of things
it's definitely smaller than the other
iphone 12 models
oh what a cute little baby it is next to
the iphone 12 pro max
it's even smaller than that original
iphone 6 design
yet has a much bigger 5.4 inch screen
that means stuff like this is way easier
to do with one hand
one hand to go there one finger to go
there
boom can even look through my widgets
i'm such a good boy you're beautiful
it's not as easy to hold like this
because the phone's not as big as the
other phones
[Music]
this is how you have to navigate phone
car yet while it has the same
cameras design and 5g speeds as the
iphone 12
the battery was a big drop just look at
these battery results of a youtube
streaming test
now the mini is also larger than a lot
of things
you can do it and don't forget it's
still bigger than some of your favorite
old iphones
so yeah it's a pretty great phone if you
don't mind giving up some battery life
and a bigger screen
that's it that's the whole review i'm
gonna do all my reviews with these